I'm going to first to lubricate my
articulate errs you know what that is
it's a travel suite of some kind it's a
loss in the travel suite that's
certainly a British ISM I've never heard
that in my life not some legends welcome
to buffeted lots of legends one little
paper to the winters would you rather be
stuck on a deserted planet with hella or
Loki well you're here and how can I
possibly not say Loki of course hello
major
I guess I just deserted island there's
only so many things you could eat like
you hello hello we'd sorted evidentially
is evil but it changed would you rather
get a deep tissue massage just you I
like guises kiss you kiss you I hardly
know you
if you say massage or massage massage
yeah I like that too either from the
Hulk's bare hands or from Thor's hammer
it's gonna be the whole spit answer me I
think I'd have to agree with you and I'm
not being biased
the idea of Thor's hammer hammering away
at my muscles
of course keeps his hammer in his
bathroom
so like that's gross I don't want that
on my bod Thor's hammer how does that
feel at a massage hot stones but cold
middle instead we'll try both
would you rather turn into the Hulk in
the middle of your wedding or in the
middle of your honeymoon doing you know
what I think part of the problem is I
can't find anybody to you know I watch
evocative images the coming to these is
a wildly section one how do you
and I'm not sure I think I'm gonna turn
into the during my honeymoon in enough
time to annul the marriage if the person
doesn't accept me for who I am or who I
can become sometimes would you rather
have dr. Bruce Banner as your primary
care physician or doctor strange I
wouldn't trust him I called dr. strange
let's say I adopted dr. butterfingers
well you should go see my doctor doctor
shaky hands that's right surgeon bad
cuts neither than the qualifies for the
job which they're not general fact what
is Bruce Banner is a scientist or
something
I mean I'm just gonna go logically dr.
strange knows more about the body yeah
then dr. banner he was a surgeon dr.
strange
would you rather Netflix and chill with
the permit Netflix and chill oh is that
you know for watching with the
permanently shrunk ant-man permanently
walked out all of you know chilling much
for the Hokie out Hawkeye yeah now you
don't get stressed out the whole time I
just did purpose our three-year-old de
trois especial of T wrote and I know
exactly I got two three votes would you
rather have to say oh oh my gosh before
you kiss anyone or before you can use
your bottle I feel comfortable
whispering Hulk smash to myself as I was
walking into the bathroom I would yell
it for me I think it's the bathroom
choice now restroom Bay Boyz yeah Hulk
smash Hulk smash
I'd rather say Hulk smash before kiss
somebody that's really romantic
Hulk smash oh oh okay okay okay yeah
great our heads it to the left and down
hall see he follows through on a scene
would you rather have a human sized body
with a hulk-sized head or a full-sized
body with a human sized head Oh sighs
part of the human head yeah probably
that really excited by the human size
that really I think you'd have a human
sized body with the whole size head like
if you find
yeah uncle pop things would you rather
have to arm-wrestle for your life
against Korg or Thor why don't you ask
Josh he's got clammy hands see where
that bend
oh look at those guns you knew you'd be
fine against anybody but I've lost ROM
wrestles against Thor repeatedly so so I
know the answers that question for me
it's called questions all right we're
getting kicked off fishing okay good
night I've enjoyed this no end that's it
thank you everybody thank you what can
we do it whoa
I think it's under there oh you fixed
your trickster